Du bist im Interview, du bist auf der Zielgerade und jetzt kommt eine Frage,
die du nicht beantworten kannst, eine mit der du nicht gerechnet hast.
Und damit das nicht passiert, erkläre ich dir jetzt, auf welche fünf Fragen
du dich unbedingt vorbereiten musst.
Du bereitest dich natürlich auf ein Interview vor, guckst dir den Job an und
die Anforderungen und so weiter.
Das hast du alles drauf. Aber es gibt halt so richtig fiese Fragen, die
meistens auch komplett sinnlos sind. Aber du musst halt darauf reagieren
können. Die 5 fiesesten Fragen stelle ich dir jetzt vor.
Es gibt schon so eine kleine tricky Frage, wo man leicht ins Fettnäpfchen
treten kann. Dazu haben wir übrigens letztens noch eine Folge aufgenommen, wie
du dein Job Interview versaust, ohne ein Wort zu sagen.
Das ist die Frage: "Wie sind Sie hergekommen?"
Die Antwort darauf ist immer - gut.
Du bist immer gut hergekommen.
Viele Leute sagen dann, ah ja, der Verkehr und ich habe im Stau gestanden und
die Deutsche Bahn, oh Gott, das geht ja gar nicht. Dann bist du schon auf
so einer Jammer-Seite. Und dann fängt dein Gegenüber auch noch an, ja stimmt,
das ist alles so schlecht und das Wetter ist so schlimm und so weiter.
Dann bist du auch schon auf so einer negativen Ebene. Und auf einer negativen
Ebene trifft man ungerne positive Entscheidungen.
Das heißt, auch wenn du mit der Titanic angereist bist und im Eismeer ist die
Titanic gesunken und du bist auf einer Eisscholle zu deinem Interview gerobbt
und geschwommen. Du bist immer gut angekommen, bist immer positiv.
Ich habe als Bonus für dich hintendran noch was vorbereitet,
womit du einen Leitfaden hast, mit dem du dich perfekt auf jedes Interview
vorbereiten kannst. Und ich geb dir noch einen Hinweis auf einen kleinen
Hack, den du für Interviews immer anwenden kannst, wo du noch besser mit
wegkommst. Vorbereitung ist alles. Je besser du vorbereitet in ein
Interview gehst, je besser du dich mit dem Unternehmen auseinandergesetzt hast,
mit den Ansprechpartnern, mit der Job Description, eventuell kennst
du auch jemanden im Unternehmen, den du nochmal fragen kannst, wie es da
abgeht, umso besser bist du da drin.
Und du hast dich natürlich schon mal auf die wichtigsten Themen vorbereitet,
wie dein Werdegang, dass du was dazu erzählen kannst.
Geschichten sind sehr, sehr stark, weil du immer sehr stark auf die Emotionen
gehst. Und damit kannst du deinen Zuhörer mitnehmen und in deine
Welt führen. Zum Beispiel, wie ich das Thema meiner Diplomarbeit gefunden habe
und dann das mit 1 abgeschlossen habe und was mir da im Weg gestanden hat.
Also, wenn du dir Geschichten zu deinem Lebenslauf überlegst, was du wo erlebt
hast, also nicht nur Fakten, dann bist du richtig gut dabei.
Also drei, vier, fünf Geschichten vorbereiten, deinen Werdegang, wenn du da
rein gehst hast du schon, sagen wir mal 70 Prozent der Miete.
Warum sollten wir sie einstellen? Das wäre schon mal so eine Frage, die ist
noch nicht so richtig fies, aber auch da kommen viele Leute schon ins
Schleudern. Aber da kannst du auf dein Repertoire zurückgreifen.
Du hast ja überlegt, okay, das sind die Anforderungen an den Job.
Das sind deine Skills und wie matchen die miteinander.
Am besten auch immer mit ein, zwei Beispielen. Also das ist das was du immer
vorbereitest und dann kannst du das genau abfeuern.
Es werden oft fiese Fragen gestellt, einfach nur, um zu sehen, wie du
reagierst. Das ist so ähnlich, wie wenn irgendjemand dir
irgendwas an den Kopf wirft, wo du erst denkst, hä, was war denn das jetzt?
Dann gibts halt zwei Reaktionen. Du kannst ausrasten, was viele Leute
machen, oder aber, und das würde ich dir für das Jobinterview empfehlen,
einmal tief durchatmen und dann überlegen, wie du Antwortest.
Dann ist nicht dein Kleinhirn, das reagiert, Flucht oder
Angriff, sondern dann kannst du halt wieder auf deine Geschichten und deine
Vorbereitung zurückgreifen.
Auch schön, warum sollten wir sie nicht einstellen?
Warum sollten wir sie nicht einstellen?
Da kannst du einfach die Frage umdrehen, warum sollen wir sie einstellen?
Okay, das kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten, aber ich könnte Ihnen mal erklären,
warum Sie mich einstellen sollen und dann vielleicht immer nochmal verweisen,
da gibt's natürlich noch Themen, wo ich etwas dazulernen kann.
Immer wieder betonen, dass du dich natürlich weiterentwickeln willst, dass du
natürlich nicht alles kannst sondern, dass du auch immer was dazulernen
möchtest. Was machst du, wenn du eine Frage nicht verstanden hast, oder wenn du
nicht richtig verstehst, was er meint, oder wenn du keine Antwort weißt?
Da gibts halt auch einen guten Verkäufer-Trick: Du gibst die Frage zurück und
sagst einfach, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so genau, was Sie damit meinen, oder
können Sie mir mal ein Beispiel nennen, was Sie damit meinen?
Und dann kommt der andere wieder.
Meistens erklärt er dir dann schon, was die Antwort sein soll.
Das ist ganz oft. Und / Oder du hast Zeit,
noch einmal darüber nachzudenken, wie du die Frage am besten beantwortest, weil
der andere dann spricht. Und die meisten Menschen hören sich gerne, reden.
Oft kann es passieren, dass er die Antwort dir dann schon selber gibt und sie
ganz toll findet und dann hast du schon mal alles richtig gemacht.
Es kommt auch schon mal vor, dass jemand sagt, ja aber hören Sie mal, der Job,
für den Sie sich bewerben,
der ist doch zwei Nummern zu groß für Sie.
Was machst du jetzt?
Durchatmen. So und dann könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel sagen,
ganz ehrlich, das hab ich nicht ganz verstanden, was meinen Sie genau damit?
Ja, weil da und da waren Sie nur ganz kurz und die Erfahrungen haben Sie gar
nicht. Das wäre schon eine sehr gute Taktik.
Oder aber du gehst halt wieder dazu, das ist im Prinzip wieder dasselbe wie,
warum sollten wir sie einstellen, dass du sagst, okay, also ich
habe den Eindruck nicht, aber lasst uns doch mal die einzelnen Punkte
durchgehen, die die Anforderungen für den Job sind, und ich erkläre Ihnen mal,
warum ich glaube, dass ich mich dafür qualifiziere.
Und schon bist du wieder in der Argumentation drin, die du vorbereitet hast.
Wichtig ist da einfach nur, nicht ausrasten, keine Panik kriegen
und so weiter, sondern am besten erst mal tief durchatmen.
Eine Pause ist auch immer ganz gut und dann entweder eine Gegenfrage stellen
oder halt wieder in dein Repertoire zurück.
Wenn jemand nach deinen Schwächen fragt, die Frage ist grundsätzlich
schwachsinnig, weil sie nichts aussagt, genauso wie, wenn Sie ein Tier wären,
was wären Sie dann oder sowas. Das ist jetzt so ein Standard, das will ich
jetzt gar nicht mehr erwähnen. Du hast dir ein paar Stärken überlegt.
Dann nimmst du deine Stärken und sagst, ja, ich bin halt sehr wissbegierig und
manchmal übertreibe ich ein bisschen.
Da verliere ich mich in so einem Buch, in einem Sachbuch und so weiter
über Programmiersprachen und so.
Dass man die Stärken einfach ein bisschen überzieht,
das ist mal ganz gut. Welche größten Schwächen hatte denn Ihr letzter Chef?
Das ist dann schon wieder ein bisschen tricky.
Und da ist meine Empfehlung, du redest
nie schlecht über deine ehemaligen Kollegen, Firmen und Chefs,
selbst wenn du auf einer Galeere warst und hinter dir einer mit der Peitsche
gestanden hat, du redest da nie schlecht drüber, weil im Kopf des
Gegenübers kommt dann immer, okay, wie wird er wahrscheinlich über mich reden,
wenn er hier mal weg ist?
Man kann natürlich sagen, dass da keine Weiterentwicklung mehr für dich war.
Aber grundsätzlich keine Kritik an der alten Firma und so weiter,
sondern eher das immer auf die Sachebene beziehen, dass man leider nicht mehr
weitergekommen ist, dass es hier interessantere Aufgaben gibt, dass es zwar
eine super Vorbereitung war, aber jetzt hier quasi eine neue Herausforderung
wartet. Das wäre nochmal ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Tipp.
Ich habe hier einen Fragebogen für dich vorbereitet, der heißt 30
Interviewfragen, die du als Bewerber kennen sollst.
Da haben wir wirklich 30 Fragen aufgelistet mit den besten Antworten
darauf, mit den besten Vorbereitungen. Die kannst du von mir bekommen.
Musst du einfach eine E-Mail schreiben an VertriebsFunk@Xenagos.de, so heißt
die Personalberatung bei der ich arbeite, Personalberatung für Vertrieb, und
dann kriegst du sie kostenfrei ohne Probleme per E-Mail.
Und jetzt noch ein kleiner Bonus Tipp hintendran.
Es kommt auch aus der Verkäuferschule und im Endeffekt ist ein
Bewerbungsgespräch nichts anderes als ein Verkaufsgespräch.
Und der Tipp ist, hast du bestimmt schon mal gehört, wer fragt führt.
Im Moment war es ja so, du bist Sachen gefragt worden und musst jetzt immer
reagieren. Der andere schießt eine Frage nach der anderen auf dich ab.
Gute Verkäufer versuchen am
Anfang reinzugehen und ihre Fragen loszuwerden.
Und welche Fragen du stellen kannst, so richtig coole Fragen, wo du das
Gespräch bestimmst, das erfährst du in der nächsten Folge hier bei YouTube.
Da freue ich mich auf dich, bei YouTube und natürlich auch im Podcast.
Bin froh, dass du zuschaust und  zuhörst.
Bis zum nächsten mal, gib alles, dein Christopher Funk.